un calme apparent alors qu'en sourdine
une dure bataille se joue pour la survie
du pôle martinique au sein de
l'université des antilles le 23 novembre
dernier une assemblée générale
d'enseignants d'administratifs et
d'étudiants s'est levé contre les
nombreuses entorses à l'autonomie du
pôle martinique subit depuis trois ans
pourtant quelques jours plus tard le
budget primitif de l'université des
antilles était votée à la majorité
en guadeloupe il prévoit notamment un
rééquilibrage financier entre l'épaule
de 7 millions d'euros au profit de la
guadeloupe qui recense le plus grand
nombre d'étudiants rééquilibrage
répartis sur 10 ans à raison de six cent
mille euros par an autre mesure une
nouvelle répartition de la masse
salariale toujours au profit de
fouillole en précisant que la guadeloupe
pourrait récupérer les postes vacants de
martinique
la réponse des élus de l'assemblée de
martinique ne s'est pas fait attendre le
lendemain en plénière ils ont voté à
l'unanimité une motion lancée par claude
lise qui dénoncent le caractère
inéquitable des transferts envisagés par
la présidence de l'université
certains élus évoquant même la création
d'une université de martinique si les
difficultés de dialogue venaient à
persister 4860 étudiants de l'uha sont
basés en martinique la guadeloupe en
compte 2000 de plus trois ans après la
scission avec l'université de guyane
ces nouvelles rivalités entre la
guadeloupe et la martinique démontre
encore la grande fragilité de l'unité
universitaire